Hey everyone. To understand and solve ...
business problems, we need to start with the basics.
People respond to incentives.
But when outcomes fall short, it's not because people are irrational.
It's because the system is this term.
You'll gather tools to diagnose these kind of problems.
We'll keep coming back to three key questions.
Who is making the bad decision?
Do they have enough information to make a good one?
And is there an incentive to make a good decision?
By the end of this course, these questions will become second nature.
Let's look at a classic problem of misaligned incentives.
On one side, leadership has clear goals.
They want to have growth, efficiency and better margins.
On the other, the frontline employees feel ...
confused, disengaged,
or worse, they're working hard in the ...
wrong direction.
What we see here isn't laziness or apathy.
It's a failure of the system design.
Our job is to ask who's making the bad decision and why?
Does that make sense to them?
Enter the rational actor paradigm.
It says people act rationally, optimally and self interestly.
They have certain incentives in place for them and they ...
want to act on those incentives.
So if we have someone making a bad decision from ...
your point of view, it probably,
probably makes perfect sense from theirs.
Which leads us to our next two questions.
Do they have the right information and do they have ...
a reason to act on it?
If we need to change their behavior,
we have to change their incentives.
Which brings us to incentives,
behavior and outcomes.
This is a loop we'll diagnose over and over.
When outcomes are off, it's usually because there's a ...
break or a distortion somewhere else in this chain.
Are the right incentives in place for your employees to ...
produce the outcomes you want?
Think of a salesperson paid on volume and not profit.
They'll sell more, but the company might earn less.
Behavior follow an incentive, not the intention.
Now let's layer in marginal analysis.
This tool helps us ask what's the next best action?
Does it pay off for the individual?
Compare the marginal benefits to the marginal cost.
If the marginal cost of doing something outweighs the ...
marginal benefit, we shouldn't be surprised ...
when people choose otherwise.
Is working one extra hour the marginal cost worth the pay?
The marginal benefit.
Here we know that the rational actor will continue an ...
activity up to the point where the marginal cost equals the ...
marginal benefit.
Beyond that, the rational actor will not ...
continue to pursue that activity.
This tool is how we zoom in on decision points and ...
assess whether incentives line up at the margin.
In a well designed system, personal gains fit perfectly ...
with organizational goals.
That's an incentive alignment.
Here we have personal goals and organizational goals not ...
fitting together.
We need them to fit together.
If we place the proper incentives in place,
then we can align the puzzle pieces.
Then everyone's doing what's best for them.
And it's also best for the team,
the firm and the customer.
Good alignment doesn't require micromanagement.
It requires structural clarity.
But alignment isn't static.
Businesses can.
Business conditions change.
People respond to what's rewarded.
That's why we build feedback loops.
We measure the outcomes, we evaluate the gap and ...
tweak the incentives.
These loops keep the systems honest and nimble.
When incentives are aligned and feedback is tight,
teams pull in unison toward shared goals.
Diversity of perspective adds strength.
Shared direction gives it focus.
And it all comes back to our three who's making the bad decision?
Do they have enough information to make a good one?
And is there an incentive to make a good decision?
We'll revisit these ideas again and again throughout the term.
Each case, each tool and each ...
framework will give us more clarity and control over the ...
messy, high stakes problems.
By the end, we'll have a mindset and ...
methods to solve.
All right, that's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.